[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous en fait quelque chose me
préoccupe
je voudrais vous parler de quelqu'un que
vous connaissez sans doute que vous
connaissez bien et peut-être qui vous
ressemble l'individu hyperconnecté alors
ce qui me préoccupe dans l'individu
hyperconnecté c'est que il est facile à
trouver
il est facile à voir dans les transports
ici tout à l'heure dans le petit sondage
auquel vous avez répondu mais finalement
pourquoi est-il hyper connectés est ce
que nous avons eu une envie soudaine est
ce que nous cédons à une mode par
exemple ou bien est-ce que nous avons
besoin d'être hyper connectés et en fait
c'est l'hypothèse que je vais développer
en considérant et on vient d'en voir une
partie avec le pic précédent que nous
vivons dans un univers dont les codes
dont les valeurs dont les règles ont
changé donc nous sommes aujourd'hui
certains auteurs le montre dans une
société qui édite hyper moderne
je pense à deux auteurs particulièrement
un philosophe allemand contemporain qui
s'appelle hartmut rosa et puis un
urbaniste français de génie qui
s'appelle françois ascher leurs travaux
nous permettent de comprendre que la
société dans laquelle nous vivons
la société hypermoderne est assise sur
deux traits caractéristiques que sont
l'accélération
tout va plus vite tout change d'une part
et que son l'amplification d'autre part
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus de choix
beaucoup plus de possibilités beaucoup
plus d'amis beaucoup plus de
possibilités de tout d'achat d'études de
déplacement et c est donc cette société
hypermoderne comme toutes les sociétés
se sont en fait c'est en fait pardon
développés se développe sous nos yeux
sur des valeurs toutes sociétés s'agrège
à des valeurs et en fait je voudrais
voir avec vous quatre valeurs qui nous
conduisent à l'hyper connexion
la première valeur il en a été question
à l'instar avec la génération easyjet
c'est la mobilité
mais il ne faut pas penser que à cette
mobilité physique géographique qui nous
permet d'aller d'un point a à un point b
mais à toutes les mobilités au sein
desquels nous vivons
des mobilités qui peuvent être
organisationnelles des mobilités qui
peuvent être relationnel y compris au
sein d'un tout petit cercle sa famille
son conjoint
donc finalement une instabilité qui né
de ces changements qui nous sont
possibles et que nous vérifions la
deuxième valeur qui est amenée par une
société hypermoderne est quelque chose
qui nous colle est là pour aujourd'hui
hr appelle ça la multi appartenance
autrement dit jouer plusieurs rôles
sociaux en même temps en même temps pas
tout à fait mais dans la même vie en
tout cas jouer plusieurs rôles sociaux
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
développer des identités des identités
dans la vraie vie je peux être chef de
service je peux être la voisine de
quelqu'un je peux être très active dans
une association où je peux simplement
faire partir de faire partie d'un
collectif comme un collectif de quartier
à chaque fois que je vais développer une
identité
je vais avoir une certaine mobilité une
certaine agilité sociale je vais passer
d'une identité à une autre et le spectre
est large certaines identités sont
avérées correspondent vraiment à notre
vie sociale dans la vraie vie
d'autres sont plus fantaisistes plus
usurpé plus cacher derrière des avatars
derrière des pseudonymes derrière des
comptes des profils donc toutes ces
identités me corresponde bien entendu
mais implique et nous le verrons ensuite
que je les manipulent à bon escient
à quel moment est ce que une identité
est intéressante à développer à
instruire à faire vivre à valoriser la
troisième valeur d'une société
hypermoderne marche avec les deux
précédentes bien entendu pour faire
cohésion sociale c'est l'ubiquité mais
je voudrais pas retenir de l'ubiquité
cette idée un peu basique qu'on serait à
deux endroits en même temps je
préférerais convoqué les univers des
identités que j'ai développées dans des
moments des espaces temps ou parallèles
ou à l'intersection des deux j'imagine
mal paru
ample la recevoir maintenant tout de
suite n'appelle vidéos perso parce qu'il
faudrait que je gère deux identités et
je me sentirai déjà en difficulté et je
choisirai bien sûr d'y renoncer
donc cette ubiquité nous permet de faire
vivre nos identités en parallèle
d'accepter l'intrusion d'un univers
porté par une identité dans une autre et
notre big 8 et elle est là elle n'est
pas seulement dans la projection que
nous pouvons avoir grâce à certains
outils certaines technologies numériques
de nous projeter dans un univers
lointain parce que la personne qui nous
souhaitons parler n'est pas sur le même
continent que nous alors voyez vous ces
trois valeurs en fait conduisent à la
quatrième qui est une valeur tout à fait
cumulatif des trois premières d'une part
et particulière la 4e valeur c'est
l'autonomie une société hypermoderne
nous donne les clés pour accomplir notre
destin on parle d'auto accomplissement
pour choisir notre vie pour nous
positionner comme nous l'entendons dans
certains cercles dans certains métiers
dans certaines compétences dans certains
univers urbains ruraux cosmopolitain etc
dont l'autonomie
je la considère comme super pouvoirs qui
nous est donnée dans la société
d'aujourd'hui la société hypermoderne
mais marvel nous a bien appris que tous
les supers pouvoirs avait des
inconvénients et l'inconvénient de ces
valeurs et de l'autonomie c'est que nous
devons choisir
nous devons choisir tout le temps nous
devons choisir de plus en plus vite
nous devons choisir sans aucune
hésitation il ne faut pas oublier que le
choix c'est un double stress le choix
d'abord qu'est ce que je vais retenir qu
est ce que je vais évincé et ensuite
dans la durée une fois que le choix est
fait est fait le bon choix n'aurais-je
pas dû choisir autre chose
dois je repartir en arrière et modifier
mon choix dans cette autonomie nous
conduit à un stress généré par le choix
ce choix soutenu par l'amplification et
l'accélération que j'ai déjà mentionné
donc l'hyper connexion est une réponse
cette situation et l'individu hyper
connectés en étant hyper connectés pour
ses capacités d'adaptation à la société
hypermoderne l'espèce humaine s'adapte
depuis fort longtemps on pourrait
remonter à l'anthropologue et historien
leroi gourhan et ressortir le silex
bifaces premier outil qui nous a permis
de nous adapter à un environnement
les paires connexion c'est l'outil
contemporain pour nous adapter à une
société hypermoderne d'abord nous avons
besoin tout simplement de la connexion
brut en quelque sorte parce que nous
devons avoir accès à des outils des
applications des logiciels des systèmes
divers et variés embarqué par exemple
qui vont nous permettre d information
des prédictions des simulations qui vont
éclairer le choix de ce fait de la
diminution du risque et du stress va
être avérés mais le problème c'est que
le lendemain le coup d'après de nouveau
il faut choisir
si je me renseigne aujourd'hui sur la
météo de demain c'est très bien mais
demain la météo de demain elle ne vaudra
rien il me faudra la météo d'après
demain donc je suis obligé sans cesse de
me connecter d'où la notion porté par le
préfixe d'hyper connexion parce que sans
cesse je doit actualiser mon niveau
d'information mes outils de prédiction
mais outils de simulation pour refaire
des choix y compris les mêmes sur un
trajet quotidien par exemple donc la
société hypermoderne par les valeurs
qu'elle nous propose nous conduit à être
des individus complètement hyper
connectés bien sûr on voit tout de suite
les avantages et les inconvénients qui
pourrait y avoir mais je voudrais
insister sur finalement la façon dont
les choses se calment relativement bien
et s'encastre s'imbriquent les unes dans
les autres
c'est à dire qu'il existe aujourd'hui un
univers un écosystème dans lequel
l'individu hyper connectée va pouvoir
s'épanouir complètement et donc vérifier
l'autonomie dont je parlais se prendre
en main décider de ses choix et être
calme sur ses choix
pas angoissé ou stressés cet écosystème
idéal pour l'individu hyperconnecté il
se vérifie par deux syntagme que nous
manipulons très fréquemment smart city
ville intelligente
autrement dit une ville un espace temps
lieu qui va nous permettre de d'être
hyper connectés pour accomplir ce que
nous avons décidé d'accomplir pour
valider le choix pour vivre nos vies
puisque nous avons plusieurs identités
alors en fait bien sûr la smart city
c'est à la fois un projet de
développement économique de marketing
territorial de développement durable de
citoyenneté les idéaux sont confus et
sont nombreux et j'ai envie de dire
qu'aujourd'hui on trouve beaucoup de
choses dans les smart city selon qu'on
se réfère à des villes capitales ou
métropoles européennes ou selon qu'on
regarde par exemple du côté de la chine
vous connaissez tous alibaba la ville
racines d'ali baba c'est la ville de
hangzhou dans la province du he siens
alibaba avec le gouvernement local a
développé tout un dispositif pour
réguler la circulation 10 millions
d'habitants beaucoup de soucis de trafic
routier autoroutier et de transport en
commun mais on va en profiter puisque on
a mis des caméras partout pour
développer un logiciel de reconnaissance
faciale et l'un dans l'autre on réglera
les flux et on introduira une société de
surveillance
mais il ya aussi et c'est à ça que je
voudrais revenir des fondamentaux dans
les idéaux de la smart cities et trois
de ses fondamentaux sur lesquels elle se
développe tout pour l'europe et pour des
pays qui ne sont pas totalitaire me
semble vraiment montré que la smart
cities et l'écosystème naturel de
l'individu hyper connectés le premier
vous pourriez répondre à ma place ou le
dire à ma place c'est la mobilité
encore une fois forcément puisque une
smart cities nous propose par beaucoup
d'outils de faciliter nos déplacements
avec des objectifs qui nous permettrait
d'alléger notre empreinte carbone ou par
exemple de propulser la ville presque
dans des idéaux de développement durable
dont nous trouvons des plateformes
je pense à la première qui s'est
développée openstreetmap mais nous
trouvons aussi des outils qui nous sont
proposés des applications pour du
covoiturage pour de l'intermodalité
commencé à pied finir en trottinette
avec au milieu du tram du train que
sais-je encore donc la mobilité cette
fois-ci vraiment géographique est un
point sensible de la smart city si la
smart cities nous propose des outils qui
facilitent notre mobilité nous aurons
tendance à être de plus en plus mobiles
et donc on voit bien comment la figure
de l'individu connectés et celle de la
smart city peuvent se rejoindre
le deuxième élément que je voudrais
vraiment mettre en avant parce qu'il me
tient à coeur c'est celui de la
participation
la smart cities poor's des idéaux d'open
gouvernement de nouvelle gouvernance de
transparence
on a eu les rencontres de la
participation presque à côté d'ici à
grenoble en début de semaine et on a vu
à quel point des mobilisations
citoyennes des collectifs citoyens
peuvent et façonner une partie de la
ville est pesé sur l'action publique
alors cette participation encore une
fois elle va passer par des outils que
nous maîtrisons en permanence et c'est
peut-être là qu'il faut jouer de nos
profils de nos identités de notre big 8
et pour contribuer soit l'action soit au
financement de l'action soit au relais
de l'action
donc on voit encore une fois que la
smart cities nous permet finalement de
dynamiser de valoriser d'exploiter les
caractéristiques de l'individu connectés
en situation d'hyper modernité et le
dernier point km la smart cities je les
gardais pour la fin parce que c'est pas
celui qui me convainc le plus mais on ne
peut pas l'oublier c'est tout simplement
de nous permettre de nous connecter
il faut qu'on puisse accéder j'aurais
envie de parler de l'âge de riffs de
l'âge de l'accès de rivkin maintenant
c'est à dire c'est la base accéder à un
réseau à d'information à une application
à d'autres sauf que cette connexion elle
est encore plus complexe encore plus
riches dans une smart city nous nous
pensons toujours où trop souvent en tout
cas la connexion entre
des humains via des technologies mais il
faut penser la connexion entre des
machines et l'environnement je ne
prendrai qu'un seul exemple la tour à
énergie positive la tour elithis qui a
été construite à strasbourg c'est la
seule connaît à l'échelle de la france
la deuxième sera bientôt introduite
enfin construite à saint-etienne donc
c'est une relation entre des
technologies des dispositifs et
l'environnement quand on pense aux
véhicules autonomes ces technologies
environnement machine environnement
l'homme est passif dans la sphère il
s'assoit il se laisse conduire la petite
navette nabli année l'illustration dans
cette connexion permanente bien sûr
c'est humain technologie humains
environnement humain machine mais c'est
aussi technologie machines technologies
environnement et quand je dis machine je
pense bien sûr à l'intelligence
artificielle ou machine learning
donc on s'aperçoit qu'on a là tout ce
qu'il faut pour que une smart city se
développe en laissant la place à des
individus hyper connecté avec comme
bénéfice que nous pourrions en attendre
vraiment de prendre nos destins en main
alors pour conclure je voudrais aller
chercher un historien c'est mon côté
universitaire qui ressort pierre
rosanvallon pierre rosanvallon est un
historien qui a écrit un ouvrage en 2011
lequel s'appelle la société des égaux et
ça sera ma conclusion si on écrit ego e
g o
autrement dit un auto accomplissement
avisé personnel une espèce de redondance
tautologie que moi pour moi par mois
avec la technologie
c'est un modèle de société un modèle de
smart cities avec une compétition avec
un objectif de développement économique
qui se développe
si par contre on écrit comme rosanvallon
la société des égaux avec la valeur
d'égalité dont bien sûr et j'ai a eu six
morts nous pouvons aussi nous servir de
ces outils pour d'autres projets de vie
et je finirai par paraphraser cet auteur
qui dit que finalement le projet qui
nous attend pour la génération c est
peut-être quand même un peu les
précédentes qui sont toujours là et
ils vieillissent de mieux en mieux c'est
de faire société
donc si le travail de l'individu
hyperconnecté c'est de faire société
il suffit de se demander laquelle je
vous remercie de votre attention
[Applaudissements]